if a jerk invades your castle can you
shoot him without a hassle
if the sheriff gets his wishes home
invaders will sleep with the fishes
we're talking about sheriff bob johnson
great name santa rosa county florida i
sound like the guy from cops santa rosa
florida
man stopped he recently announced how a
brave homeowner shot a burglary suspect
but was afraid to come forward because
they thought they might get in trouble
where do you think he was california
in the golden state you have to give
burglars an avocado wrap and a roll of
charmin for when they poop on your
doorstep
i know that for a fact
but on the contrary in the sun's out
guns out state this sheriff prefers you
shoot at intruders in fact you're more
than welcome to stand your ground while
you squeeze off a few rounds
if somebody's breaking in your house
you're more than welcome to shoot them
in santa rosa county we prefer that you
do actually
wow that's one way to reduce crime scene
paperwork and floridians can spend the
tax savings on lower back tattoos
but doesn't that sound reckless if only
they were there were a gun safety class
they offered every other saturday that
could make you shoot a lot better and
hopefully save the taxpayers money
we have a gun safety class we put on
every other saturday and if you take
that you'll shoot a lot better and
hopefully you'll save the taxpayers
money wow
a class that supports the second
amendment but doesn't teach toddlers to
do lap dances no wonder liberals hate
florida
[Laughter]
thank you for that sometimes silence is
awesome
it was the eye move after it was like
the olive and the martini thing think
yes
now you're that you're talking michael
uh
[Laughter]
shooting intruders isn't that how you
get your wardrobe
singer
singer
i love this story i love this sheriff
this is the spirit we need again in
america
right we need more sheriff's going shoot
them yourself it's like a real john
wayne thing go ahead just pop a cap in
their ass we'll come and collect the
body it's great though but like if you
do this which i highly encourage it to
if there's a home intruder just bang
bang bang i think you should also get
some money back off your taxes because
you kind of did the cop's job right
right it's like uh that would but that
might be an incentive to just start
shooting anybody yes
yeah
but just the bad guys right yeah it's
like when they started giving you your
own cup at mcdonald's oh wait oh i have
to fill this up but i'm still paying the
same amount
right i don't like that
i need i need my super sized meal needs
to come down and yeah but you know how
you save that you save money by keeping
the cup in your car and you keep going
back in and pretending you just bought a
new cup we learned something about
graphics are like bite marks yes there's
a lot of problems i have a lot of
problems casey my problem with shooting
intruders and i think you'll agree being
a woman
i don't you know i have a lot of windows
in my house uh and i don't want a corpse
ruining my hardwood floors so there's a
there's a is there is it may be better
to drag the person out get the person
outside i think that's against the law
why don't you just get a lot of cameras
in like lasers like trip lasers like spy
stuff oh that's fine
so you can see them coming just there's
there's a lot of
tech guys now that'll do in home
panic rooms and they have you know the
steel things that come down around the
bedrooms and then they have a hole for
the shotgun
oh i like that yes
so maybe put some like nice tiles no
you're global mansions you should know
all the did those mansions have those
that's where you did a decommissioned
missile silo in kansas in the middle of
a field in kansas and it has a whole
arms uh room a gun range you can stay in
there with the door shut for five years
oh wow yes
it's like your childhood cat
you know uh cat you're a libertarian so
you must applaud the murder of intruders
i like i don't understand how this is
controversial
[Laughter]
i don't i really don't like what what
are you supposed to do like ask them if
they you know need help finding anything
like of course you shoot them mm-hmm i
don't know i don't understand how it's
that controversial i really don't you
know what i think is great about this
tyrus it's not necessarily uh enforcing
or asking people to do this but it cre
it turns like it makes home invaders
think twice like it could be russian
roulette for them they don't know what
house yeah but they know in new york
they picked the wrong house don't pick
the wrong house because but the one
thing he said and i think you have to
keep repeating it he said gun safety
classes yes yes you have to learn how to
fire a gun it's not like the movies
well
yes you know yeah except even in the
movies it's a little dangerous but yeah
but the point is is that a lot of crimes
that happen to people is their own guns
get turned against them because they buy
it it's shiny it looks cool and they
pull it and they don't know what they're
doing right and the intruder typically
does so yeah if someone comes in your
house it's thanksgiving man shoot the
turkey but
just make sure you know what you're
doing i think it's very important that
you have gun safety classes and know how
to take care of your gun and know how to
quickly load it and unload it and handle
your business yeah and i think you know
we're living at a time where you know
there are fewer police officers from
defunding you know may not be the last
resort it may be your only resort well
plus you won't have to see him next week
when he robs you again yeah exactly
because the recidivism yeah that is
actually a better point because what if
you call the police they arrest him and
then he's back out again he's going to
come back for more right
yeah
right mad i don't think anyone would rob
twice i'm pretty annoying what are you
talking about with your giant house on
the internet
you didn't know that gut phil did you
what she has a giant house
because that means they know they know
like they find people that you know or
work with and they'll go like don't go
like uh tire well i'm trying to find
some michael loftus horrible marriage
and i'll click on it and you're not
there but i've clicked on it
anyway it's funny those clickbait things
get me every time hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else